president biden refuses to tell
americans key details about the pipeline
hack that could lead to it happening
again
and those crippling gas shortages are
getting worse
in some places 80 percent of stations
are completely out
then there's bayen refusing to say if he
knew about colonial pipeline
reportedly paying ransom to the hackers
and for years democrats blamed
russia for literally everything but
biden now says putin
not involved we do not believe the
russian government was involved in this
attack
but we do have strong reason to believe
that the criminals
who did the attack are living
in russia that's where it came from
so biden biden cleared the
the kremlin in a week juan case closed
fbi took care of it he's clean
you don't think that's a little strange
well i'm gonna i i i wanna think that's
strange let me let me just say
let me just say this to you jesse this
gas thing this crisis
is over there's no shortage of gas
anymore
i mean right now you might be dealing
with distribution
but there's no over the screen about
people can't get gas i'm just
no i'm just telling you there's no gas
shortage it might be distribution
there's no there's no shortage of gas
all this alarmist talk has led to
semantics hispanic buying okay
all right but as for biden and this
hacking
you know to me what you've got is a
crime syndicate
operating out of russia and we don't
know
our intelligence people are unable to
ascertain for sure
that it was something done by putin or
at putin's request
so i think what they didn't clear them
they just say they don't know
they don't know that putin was
responsible at this point
and i think that rather than act in some
rash matter
there is no penalty to thinking
strategically because
you know jesse we said this yesterday
this amounts to an
act of war against us and if we are
acting strategically as in war we've got
to anticipate
the next step and so acting rationally
oh yeah we're going to
just make a show of bravado is foolish
all right well martha after hillary was
embarrassed because a few emails came
out
that she was worried about a bimbo
eruption in 2016
democrats wanted to start world war iii
with the russians
now putin's innocent no evidence of
anything
that's convenient it is convenient and i
think that juan touched on something
about
you know we can't fight the last war you
always have to fight the next war
so whether or not putin is directly
involved we know that there had to have
been some sort of tacit approval of this
because that's the way things work in
the soviet union
even if this came at the corporate level
but you have to look at how bad actors
all around the globe look at this
this event and they know that they can
[ __ ]
a third of the united states by hacking
into our energy systems
so we have to be ready to fight cyber
warfare even
viral warfare now whether or not there
was any you know malintent
and what happened with this virus
escaping look at the impact
so that is another thing that bad actors
watch very closely
look at these um direct energy attacks
that american officers have suffered in
cuba
in russia in china so all of these
things we can't squabble
over whether or not there was a direct
link to putin we need to understand that
this is the future of warfare
and we need to be in front of it we
cannot sit back and say well that's over
that was the oh that went that went okay
we're done with that
yeah will kane it looked to me when he
was asked about the ransom
and he said no comment that tells me he
signed off on the ransom to russian
hackers
what kind of precedent does that set a
bad one
i thought we didn't negotiate with
terrorists we didn't negotiate for
hostages we don't pay ransoms why
because it begs for more of that same
kind of attention i do like your point
jesse by the way
russia has been guilty of every sin
under the sun for more than four years
but all of a sudden now
they're innocent in a couple days time
nothing happens in russia this type of
thing doesn't happen in russia without
at least putin's knowledge
these hackers are often off duty state
actors
and by the way i want to indulge the
semantic battle for just one second
if child care is infrastructure if court
packing is infrastructure if systemic
racism is infrastructure
if everything is infrastructure can we
submit that our nation's pipelines that
need to
need to be protected that's
infrastructure maybe we can invest in
ensuring no more cyber attacks
if we just call it infrastructure which
it is it kennedy
it was interesting that the fbi with
trump
it was guilty until proven innocent but
with putin
he's innocent until proven guilty well
and the fbi is still
very guilty of many omissions
as they were in some of the reports we
saw
after the russian collusion special
investigation
uh but he's will is absolutely right
because
you know here we have not only critical
infrastructure which
that now needs to be bumped to the top
of the list for infrastructure
legislation and about 70 percent of it
needs to go away that's not actual
infrastructure and now we can use big
words like big
people and talk about what
infrastructure
really is and it's not just pipelines
that have to be protected we have to
protect
satellites and power grids and you know
all the different ways that we get and
use energy in this country because
it's not hard to think how we could be
completely paralyzed
especially when we are incentivizing
this
kind of behavior so yes i don't trust
the fbi i don't trust the federal
government
this is why i'm a libertarian because
they have the wrong priorities
and they usually get everything wrong
when they try and go big
well i think if putin had hacked the
solar grid
biden would have been pretty angry about
that he's gonna hack the sun
up next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else